hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today was a bit more of a
unexpected video I was actually I'm
actually in the process of making a
completely different video on the shaman
it should be out either tomorrow or
Friday or maybe later tonight I will
have to figure that out but as I was
scrolling through Reddit while I was in
the middle of editing it I noticed that
there was a video about this new map
called Gran's guard and I wanted to talk
to you about it and kind of show you
about what's what's going on about is
let's get started so first up the reddit
post will be in the description if you
do want to also see all the images and
also shout out to [ __ ] the demon for do
putting this on reddit once again link
will be in the description and all that
good stuff but the first image is
basically showing this dude to be
chewing with a bunch of his friends just
the four guys and they got this new map
and it looks different it's definitely
now it's definitely never been in the
playlist we've never seen this map
before and it happened to be called
Gran's guard now obviously it's in
Russian text because of his cuz he said
that it was because of his region lock
because maybe he lives in Russia but
either way the map does say Gran's guard
it's also a brawl map now the
interesting thing about this map is that
this is actually the area from the
campaign if any of you played the
campaign it's the mission where you play
it as law bringer and you had to fight
the Raider boss on the ice and the ice
functions the exact same way with the
more you stay on the ice the more the
ice cracks until it eventually crumbles
and then if you're on that ice when it
falls you end up dying so it's a normal
bra map but with this type of feature
there are a few gifts and stuff like
that of the guys kind of screwing around
[ __ ] around on the map and by the way
this map looks very nice and it'll
definitely it's probably going to
obviously get a lot smaller the more the
map goes because obviously the more you
step on it the more that the ice will
crumble and then that means that the map
is going to get smaller now I want to
figure out is if you were on let's say
one side of the map and you're sitting
on ice and somebody else is on the other
side of the map but you guys can't get
to each other let's say like the path
that used to be filled with ice is now
blocked how is that going to work maybe
you just kind of sit there and hope and
pray that their ice block crumbles
before you do whatever that the case may
be by the way this map does look very
nice and I don't know when this will be
coming out it may be it might be coming
out
and Christmastime seeing as it's an ice
map maybe it's a little bit of a teaser
I'm not entirely sure or this could be
coming in later of season four or who
knows maybe season five I doubt it
though that's way too far ahead is
seeing as we just got to season four who
knows we'll have to wait and see
but there are a few bugs with this map
apparently because obviously this isn't
technically supposed to be in the game
one of the bugs was saying is if you run
from the ice platform to another
platform at the exact same time is when
the original one breaks you visibly die
but technically not it shows that you're
dead like your body's kind of flopped
over but you're not actually dead so you
might be kind of like T posing and
walking around the map and then there
was an instance where one of the players
of the match was actually underneath the
ice and still alive but couldn't damage
anyone
also what I'm from hearing from the
comments and the reddit post and all
this other stuff is that you can
actually trigger this map to play it on
your own you have all you have to do is
just go into a custom game and then
click on brawl and then if it does them
if the map doesn't show up you go to
duel and then go back to brought you
keep refreshing the ball the brawl map
until it eventually pops up it's just a
random chance it might not even come up
it might take a while but either way you
can't just select the map because
obviously it's not actually in the game
so you just have to go from brawl then
back to duel and then back to brawl
until it eventually will show up in the
brawl section and that's actually how
you get to play on the map so yeah
obviously this map is going to be bugged
filled with random stuff obviously
because this isn't supposed to be in the
game either way though this map does
look nice it is from the campaign and I
actually really did enjoy the the
campaign especially this mission so I
can't wait to be fighting on the ice map
let me guys know what you think about
the about this new map grants guard what
when you think it'll come out and all
that good stuff I'd love to know in the
comments below but that's gonna be it
for the video today guys once again very
short video completely went unexpected I
was actually like I said in the middle
of making another video that should be
out in the next couple days hopefully
you got hopefully you guys will like
that and also agree with my points in
that one but if you did like the video
please be sure to give it a like it
really does help me out and if you're
new subscribe for more for honor content
I post a lot of leaks news discussions
all that stuff above for honor my two
most recent videos are gonna be popping
up on screen now if you guys did missed
those you can click on that
but with that guys I hope you have a
great rest of your day and peace out
take care